Professor John
Merriman: I'm going to talk
about anarchism today,
and especially I'm going to
talk about the life and death of
one guy,
somebody I don't admire,
Émile Henry;
but, in a way he represents
some aspects of the origin of
modern terrorism in late
nineteenth-century Paris.
And, I guess if you're going to
write a book about somebody it's
not a bad idea to pick someone
who only lived to be age
twenty-one,
because it makes for a shorter
book;
because he was guillotined,
as you'll see,
in 1894.
So, there we go.
First of all,
anarchists, unlike socialists,
did not want to capture the
State, seize control of the
State.
They wanted to destroy the
State, they wanted to abolish
the State.
They viewed political
participation--and in this way
they were rather like the
syndicalists--as for propping up
capitalism and its army,
defending the interests of
wealthy people.
The first anarchist was a man
called Proudhon,
whose influence really is in
the 1850s and 1860s.
And Proudhon is from the east
of France, he was from
Besançon,
in the east.
And he once wrote a pamphlet
called "Property is Theft," in
1841--he meant too much property
or unearned property was
theft--but it was a provocative
kind of title,
and he once wrote the
following: "To be governed is to
be watched, inspected,
spied upon, directed,
law-driven, numbered,
regulated, enrolled,
indoctrinated,
preached at,
controlled, checked,
estimated, valued,
censored, commanded by
creatures who have neither the
right,
nor the wisdom,
nor the virtue to do so.
To be governed is to be at
every operation,
at every transaction,
noted, registered,
counted, taxed,
stamped, measured,
numbered, assessed,
licensed, authorized,
admonished, prevented,
forbidden, reformed,
corrected, punished,
and on the pretext of public
utility and in the name of the
general interest to be placed
under contribution,
drilled, fleeced,
exploited, monopolized,
extorted from,
squeezed, hoaxed,
robbed;
and then, at the slightest
resistance, the first word of
complaint could be repressed,
fired upon, vilified,
harassed, hunted down,
abused, clubbed,
disarmed, bound,
checked, imprisoned,
judged, condemned,
shot, deported,
sacrificed, sold,
betrayed and,
to crown all,
mocked, ridiculed,
derided, outraged,
dishonored.
That is government,
that is its justice,
that is its morality."
Now, Proudhon was followed by
two important Russian
anarchists, both of whom I won't
talk about,
but who are extremely
interesting, and both of whom
were nobles, one the guy called
Peter Kropotkin and the other
the terrifying,
quite terrifying Mikhail
Bakunin, and they become quite
important.
Kropotkin, who was a gentleman
geographer and once toasted by
the King of England,
and in the end was horrified by
the Bolshevik Revolution,
he was among those who came up
with the term "propaganda by the
deed";
that is, the belief that the
masses were potentially
revolutionary,
and it took a single spark,
a single assassination,
a single bomb to start
revolution rolling.
Anarchists assassinated,
depending on how you count it,
five, or six,
or seven heads of state in the
late decades of the nineteenth
century,
including President McKinley of
the United States,
who was shot or stabbed,
I can't remember which,
in Buffalo, New York in 1901.
That number included,
as we'll see in awhile,
Sadi Carnot,
c-a-r-n-o-t,
who was the president of
France.
So, I want to begin with a bomb.
And I've had,
because of this bomb,
years and years afterward--I've
had the rather odd feeling of
twice having eaten in the
café restaurant that my
book subject blew up,
the Café
Terminus--and it is the turning
point in the origins of modern
terrorism.
On February 12th,^( )1894,
a pale, thin young man called
Émile Henry prepared a
bomb in his room in Paris.
He hid it in his clothing along
with a loaded pistol and a
knife, and he headed toward the
elegant boulevards near the
Paris Opera,
which had been completed twenty
years earlier.
He wanted to throw the bomb and
kill as many people as possible.
Henry stopped before the Opera
itself, which,
as you can see,
resembles a giant gilded
wedding cake.
There was a fancy ball going
on, and he knew he could not get
past the guards to get close
enough to claim any victims.
He then checked out the
Restaurant Bignon,
followed by the Café
American,
and then the most chic of them
all, the Café
de la Paix in the Grand Hotel,
which is still there.
He was in some way a
flâneur,
an intellectual who had briefly
in his life been something of a
dandy,
but if so he was an
impoverished
flâneur who lived
on the margins of urban life and
who now came to the Grand
Boulevard not just to observe
with detached distance,
as the flâneur
did, but to hate,
and now to kill.
He moved on,
finding each place was not
crowded enough.
At eight p.m.
he reached the Café
Terminus, right next to the
Gare Saint-Lazare,
around the corner from the Gare
Saint-Lazare and,
as the café
was slowly filling up,
he ordered a beer,
and soon another,
and then a cigar,
and in a rather
un-anarchist-like gesture he
paid for them,
as the small orchestra played
on.
About an hour later he walked
to the doorway,
turned, lit the fuse with a
cigar.
He threw the bomb back into the
café, which was now very
crowded.
Already famous for its great
expositions, Paris,
more than ever identified with
leisure and with consumerism,
had become a permanent
exposition in itself,
its boulevards the staging
ground,
as you shall see later in the
course, for the Belle
Époque.
Department stores welcomed
clients with dazzling electric
lights and arranged shop windows
inspiring Zola to call them 'the
cathedrals of modernity."
The aisles of the department
stores were, as has been argued,
a continuation of the great
boulevards themselves.
In contrast,
the poor workers lived along
the narrow grey streets of the
quartiers
populaires--this is not a
quartier populaire,
this is the Terminus--the
plebeian neighborhoods of
eastern Paris,
where cholera had killed as
late as 1884.
The rebuilding of Paris by
Haussmann in the fifties and
sixties had chased thousands of
ordinary people,
by higher rents,
to the exterior neighborhoods
of northern Paris,
northeastern Paris,
and to the working class
suburbs.
But the capital of the world,
that is, Paris,
was no longer the capital of
revolution.
Soldiers in Paris seemed to
be--police and soldiers seemed
to be everywhere,
and there were indeed many more
of them.
For that matter,
Haussmann's boulevards were too
wide for barricades.
To Auguste Renoir,
the Impressionist painting,
the buildings that lined the
boulevards were,
"cold and lined up like
soldiers at review," a nice
description of the consolidation
of State power in
nineteenth-century France.
On May Day 1891,
troops fired on demonstrators,
killing women and children in
the small industrial town in the
north of Fourmies,
a woolens town.
France may not then have had
strong executive authority
because of the fear of
Caesarism, after two Napoleons,
but no other state was so
centralized.
And, so, in the early 1890s did
anarchists begin to create small
organizations,
along La Mouffe,
which is the Rue Mouffetard,
between the Pantheon where a
guy called Jean Grave published
one of the anarchist newspapers
at number 140,
here and there in the Latin
Quarter, but above all in
Montmartre and in these northern
industrial regions,
and beyond in suburbs.
Now, the 1880s and '90s will,
as you may already know,
will be remembered as a time of
scandal--the sleazy Panama Canal
scandal and lots of other ones;
the president's son-in-law
selling the Légion
d'Honneur, et cetera.
And the memory of the Paris
Commune loomed large for
anarchists.
More than 25,000 people had
been gunned down,
and now from the heights of
Montmartr,
e and from Belleville,
another peripheral
neighborhood,
anarchists looked down on the
flashing lights of the capital,
and they hate it.
Many admired the Russian
anarchist Michael Bakunin for
whom destruction was "a creative
passion that would bring about
the end of the State,
capitalism, and private
property."
"The modern state," Bakunin
wrote, "with all its terrible
means of action given to them by
modern centralization,
was becoming an immense,
crushing, threatening reality,"
as those slaughtered communards
saw up close in May of 1871.
And, so, a wave of anarchist
bombings swept the capital
between 1892 and 1894.
They ended with the
assassination of Sadi Carnot in
June of that year in Lyon.
After two attempts on his life,
King Humberto I of Italy noted
that assassination was "a
professional risk,"
and, indeed,
he was later assassinated
himself.
Yet, many of the anarchists
were people of peace,
indeed, and women of peace in
the case of Louise Michel,
about whom you can read.
For Kropotkin and before him
Proudhon, the goal was the
primitive, the goal was sort of
communities that would exist
without the state.
Kropotkin had lived in the
French Jura mountains,
in the east,
and also in Switzerland,
and their watchmakers seemed to
get along fine without the
intrusion of the state.
But yet, as I said before,
it was Kropotkin who accepted
and may have created the phrase,
"propaganda by the deed,"
sometimes attributed to the
Italian anarchist Malatesta who
had lots of influence in Spain,
in Italy and in Argentina;
who doesn't look like such a
terrifying guy himself,
when you see him there,
but again the belief that a
single act of violence would be
the spark that would bring
social revolution.
Now, Kropotkin later had doubts
about this, and he said,
"personally I hate these
explosions,
but I cannot stand as a judge
to condemn those who are driven
to despair."
He had, after all,
in 1880, described the
importance of permanent revolt
by oral and written propaganda,
by the knife,
the rifle and dynamite.
"Everything that is not legal
is good for us."
Now, dynamite was invented by
that man of the Peace Prize,
Alfred Nobel,
in 1868.
And what it seemed to do was
level the playing field.
It seemed to represent a modern
revolutionary alchemy,
and as a compensation for many
evils,
for humiliation and weakness,
for discrimination and
frustration, anger at social
exploitation and injustice.
The German anarchist,
Johan Most, who came to the
United States,
he had written in his newspaper
Freedom that it was
within the power of dynamite to
destroy capitalism,
just as it had been within the
power of gunpowder and the rifle
to wipe feudalism from the face
of the earth.
And American anarchists crowed,
before being hung in Chicago,
Haymarket, 1886,
"in giving dynamite to the
downtrodden millions of the
globe, science has truly done
its best work."
The famous Ravachol,
Francois Claudius Ravachol,
took this to heart.
He had been born in gnawing
poverty near Saint-Etienne in
'59, his father a Dutch mill
hand who abandoned his wife and
four children.
In primary school and at Mass
he was embarrassed by having
clothes so shabby that they
resembled those worn by beggars.
He worked here and there,
but periods of unemployment
became longer.
He turned toward anarchism,
also to grave robbing,
counterfeiting,
and finally murder,
strangling a strange old hermit
who had a lot of money stashed
away in his house in the hills,
near Saint-Etienne.
He was arrested,
managed to escape the police
wagon, and went to Paris living
under an assumed name.
In 1891 police fired on
demonstrators on the Boulevard
Clichy in Paris,
on the edge of Paris.
Three were hauled to the Police
Station and they were beaten up,
put on trial and two condemned
to long prison sentences.
Ravachol's two deeds followed.
He bombed the houses of two of
the magistrates on the Boulevard
Saint-Germain,
a very elegant neighborhood,
and on the Rue du Clichy,
voilà.
On the way home he stopped in a
restaurant called Le
Véry, v-e-r-y,
with an accent,
on the Boulevard Magenta.
A waiter remembered a scar he
had on his left hand.
Three days later he went back
to the same place to eat,
because he'd eaten well.
It took ten policemen to subdue
him.
"See this hand," he told judge
and jurors, "it has killed as
many bourgeois as it has
fingers."
He was guillotined on the 11th
of July 1892 in the Loire,
in Montbrison.
Several days later a bomb
destroyed the restaurant,
Le Véry,
killing the patron,
the owner, leading to the
ghoulish pun that served as an
anarchist signature,
vérification.
Ravachol so terrified
contemporaries that for a time
his name became a French verb;
to ravacholiser
quelqu'un,
somebody, was to dynamite them.
And after his death the
anarchists of Paris and their
exiled friends in London,
from all over the continent,
debated long into the night the
wisdom of such attacks.
A wood print--here you can see
it--by the artist Charlotte
Morin, reproduced in a widely
read anarchist newspaper,
portrayed Ravachol as a martyr,
his defiant,
heroic face set within the
frame of the guillotine.
Some sympathizers began to
compare their martyr,
Ravachol, to sort of a violent
Jesus Christ.
Both Christ and Ravachol were
thirty-three when they were
executed.
And anarchists sang a song
called La Ravachol,
that is, The Song of Ravachol,
to the tune of Ça
Ira, a song from the French
Revolution: "In the great city
of Paris live the well-fed
bourgeois and the destitute who
have empty stomachs,
but they have long teeth.
Long live Ravachol,
let's dance the Ravachol;
long live the sound of
explosions.
So it will be,
so it will be,
ça ira."
In his eulogy for Ravachol,
an anarchist critic,
art critic, and literary
critic, Paul Adam,
warned that the murder of
Ravachol will open an era;
and it did.
An anarchist writer outraged
public opinion by provocatively
stating, "what do the victims
matter if the gesture is
beautiful?"-- the beau
geste.
A veritable psychosis took hold
of Paris with people of means
afraid to go to good restaurants
or the theater and in nice
neighborhoods people fearing to
rent to magistrates for fear of
les dynamiteurs,
the dynamiters.
Nearly twenty Parisian dailies
carried each installment of
anarchist attack-- this is a
bomb,
this is called a marmite,
it's a pan, it's a casserole,
but it's a bomb.
Hundreds of scrawled--and
here's the first,
they invented at this time the
wagons that'd come to detonate,
and to make safe as best they
can these objects,
and they kept finding joke
bombs in sardine cans,
and stuff like that.
And, so, here's the municipal
chemist, a guy called Girard,
who's checking this out.
Hundreds of scrawled threats,
which I read,
they're in the Archives there,
arrived to property owners and
to concierges,
to people of means,
signed by the Avengers of
Ravachol;
or an anarchist from the
neighborhood addressed to an
exploiter of the proletarian,
"finally the day when social
justice will arrive;
next Sunday,
the First of May,
you'll be blown up;
signed, La Dynamite."
And in Montmartre,
a benefit dance for anarchists
played the dynamite polka,
as one of the dances.
The well-known next act.
On the ninth of December,
1893, Auguste Vaillant,
an unemployed worker distraught
at being unable to feed his
family,
tossed a small bomb filled with
tacks, thumb tacks,
into the Chamber of Deputies.
His goal was not to kill--there
were several scratches on the
deputies--but to call attention
to the plight of the poor whose
situation seemed to be getting
worse and worse.
He was captured on the spot.
The guillotine immediately,
instantaneously,
after a brief trial,
severed his head as he
defiantly shouted the
obligatory, "long live anarchy."
Émile Henry's father,
a militant republican,
who wrote poetry,
had been elected to the Commune
from the tenth arrondissement,
and was a member of the Central
Committee of the Federated
National Guard in the Paris
Commune.
He fled under a sentence of
death to Spain.
And in Catalonia he worked in
the mines, turning from
socialism to anarchism;
because the anarchists were
terribly influential in Spain,
right through the Spanish Civil
War,
particularly in Barcelona and
also in Andalusia,
in the south.
Émile was born in 1872
in a suburb of Barcelona,
dominated by the textile
factories.
He had two brothers,
Fortuné,
who was older,
who had the same name as his
father, and Jules,
who was fifteen in 1894.
Following his father's death in
1882, from what appeared to be
mercury poisoning,
Madame Henry returned to Paris
with her children,
or to the region.
Émile became a pupil of
the City of Paris,
receiving the equivalent of a
scholarship to a school outside
of Paris.
His mother bought or had a
little bit of land that had been
in the family and found--started
up an auberge,
right down the street from
this, it was actually an inn.
I was actually able to find it,
to go out to this place called
Brévon,
which now, sort of strangely
enough, is not all that far from
Euro Disney, but then was truly
in the countryside.
So, Émile Henry becomes
a scholarship student.
He's very smart,
he gets certificates of merit
in all the schools he goes to,
and he gets his bac,
his baccalaureate exam;
he passes it at age sixteen,
which was pretty tough to do.
He was examined in physics,
math and chemistry,
and he would put some of the
latter to use,
as we shall see.
The last report on his
scholarship read,
"he will begin studies next
year at the école
polytechnique,"
which is one of the grands
écoles,
the big military engineering
school,
extraordinarily hard to get in.
He was classified as
admissible,
that is, he could be admitted.
But after passing one part of
the exam he failed the oral
exam, but he could have taken it
again.
He claimed that one of his
friends threw a stink bomb into
the room when he was taking the
exam.
And it was said later that he
vowed vengeance on bourgeois
society, blah-blah-blah.
That wasn't the case.
He took a position with an
uncle, an engineer working on a
water project in Venice,
but he precipitously returned
to France.
He dabbled in spiritism,
trying to contact the soul of
his dead father--that's where
you try to move tables around
and all of that.
His anarchist friend Charles
Malato claimed that he lost his
footing, and fell into the abyss
of spiritism,
even becoming a medium of
incarnation, and wasted his
health in such exhausting
experiments because he longed
for knowledge.
But he left it all behind and,
in Paris, he worked here and
there while living on the
margins of urban life.
His brother,
Fortuné,
became an anarchist and was a
prominent orator at the meetings
and debates held in smoky halls
and cafés on the edge of
Paris,
principally Montmartre,
and the Faubourg du Temple,
and in the Latin Quarter,
and he went to jail in 1894 for
things that he'd written.
Émile,
now twenty years of age--et
vous voilà,
pas mal,
parmi vous--he was
called microbe by his
classmates because of his
relatively small size.
He was pale,
deep-set black eyes,
as you saw, and sported the
beginnings of a blonde beard on
his chin, to go with chestnut
hair.
He was devoted to his mother
and would walk,
or take the train out to not a
really nearby station,
to go and visit her.
And there was a bar,
several tables with workers
drinking wine,
the inevitable checkered
tablecloths,
green shutters and a red brick
roof, and chickens poking around
and laundry hanging out to dry.
As I said, it was a village.
And of the 120 francs that
Émile Henry earned a
month, he gave about a third to
his mother.
Here she is down below,
and there she is up above,
on the left--prematurely aged.
And that is one of the places
that he lived that we'll see
later, and where I--I've been to
everywhere that he lived.
I've managed to get into the
buildings of everywhere he
lived;
sort of, you kind of walk
around and follow him.
I don't admire him,
but it's interesting to try to
see what he saw,
and that's what I really love
about history.
Anyway, so he began meeting
with some of the anarchist
groups.
He read Kropotkin's great book,
The Conquest of Bread,
as well as works by Malatesta
and various French counterparts.
His two targets were private
property and authority,
"two vicious germs," as he
called them,
that formed the base of
contemporary societies that,
he wrote, "have to be
destroyed,
eradicated from social life."
He remained an intellectual,
somewhat detached,
arguably, from those people who
crowded into these anarchist
meetings,
or who came to get,
for once, a bite to eat in the
various lectures where soup was
served to the poor afterward.
In contrast to Vaillant,
who loved the people--Vaillant
was the guy executed for
throwing the tack bomb--Malato
remembered Émile only
loved the idea;
he felt a marked estrangement
from the ignorant and servile
plebs, plebeians,
a feeling distinctive,
also, of a number of literary
and artistic anarchists,
by whom he met no less a
painter than Camille Pissarro,
who was an anarchist.
And Montmartre also was the
center of this sort of literary
and cultural anarchism,
the anarchism of this sort of
the intellectual elite who lived
in Montmartre because it was
cheaper,
and they're the next generation
removed down to
Montparnasse--and then
Montmartre would already become
the sort of the tourist trap it
is now,
though it still has its charms.
Émile Henry was a loner.
He never spoke in public,
as far as we know,
though he did shout out some
things at a meeting once.
He was described later,
after his death,
as the Saint-Just of anarchy.
Saint-Just was one of the--was
a cold, steely guy who had
ripped off his mother's silver
during--before the French
Revolution,
who became a member of the
Committee of Public Safety,
and he and Robespierre were the
sort of main men of the
Committee of Public Safety.
So, he didn't speak like
Fortuné,
who was a really gifted orator.
And in March 1893,
Fortuné
gave a speech at this one place
where they met over and over
again,
denouncing the government class
and the bourgeoisie,
and he appeared to pull a
dynamite cartridge from--he
said,
"this is our arms,
these are our arms," and he
appeared to pull a dynamite
cartridge from his pocket.
It actually was nothing but a
pen, or a pen case,
but he was arrested,
and so was Émile.
And Émile lost his job,
at that point he worked in the
garment industry.
I love this because here's the
Rue du Sentier in the center of
Paris and that's still--the sign
is so beautiful from the 1890s
that they left it there;
that company hasn't been there
since World War I.
But that's where Émile
worked, but he lost his job
after he was arrested and then
released.
He bounced between bad jobs,
once working as an apprentice
and unpaid watchmaker in order
to perhaps work on timing
mechanisms for bombs.
In 1892--and he always got very
good--employers loved him
because he was very smart.
He served as an accountant,
he penned letters and that kind
of stuff.
But in 1892 he briefly served
as the manager for the
Anarchist Literary,
a newspaper.
In the meantime he was
gathering materials to make
bombs and learning how to
prepare them.
That July he and his brother
may have gone to Saint-Etienne
and Montbrison with the
intention of blowing up the
house of the magistrate in
Ravachol's trial down there
but--and I went to Saint-Etienne
to try to find if he actually
went there,
and the police think he did but
I have no positive proof of
that.
Anyway, he--the police
informants, and the police were
everywhere.
If you want to see this,
Joseph Conrad has a wonderful
novel called The Secret
Agent, and G.K.
Chesterton has another one
called The Man Who Would be
Thursday,
in which all seven anarchists
in this anarchist group turn out
to be police spies;
and London was just riddled
with police spies,
watching the Dutch,
and Spanish,
and French, and Russian,
and Czech anarchists,
and all of the others.
But, anyway,
he was overheard telling
somebody, "I didn't put enough
nitroglycerin into this one and
it didn't work,
but I'm going to put a little
more acid next time and we'll
see what happens."
And the police report,
which I've seen,
assigned him the number
318,532, and so he had a police
existence, which was good for
me.
The police, as I said,
had infiltrated these groups.
One of the police spies,
who was known as X number 4,
reported that the old ways of
the anarchists no longer seemed
to be in play,
that where anarchists had used
to go to these big halls where
the police were scribbling
notes,
and identifying everybody who
was there, that the ones you had
to worry about were not the ones
who were in the hall giving
speeches but the ones who were
lurking in the shadows,
looking for other people,
with evil deeds,
as it were, in mind.
They were the ones who would
show up and then leave quickly.
These were the most violent
ones, the ones who were capable
of carrying out propaganda by
the deed.
They were not the
halbeurs,
the posers, or the boasters;
they were off by themselves.
And they reflected a debate
within anarchist circles between
the associationalists,
who would end up being
syndicalists,
and those who believed in
individual autonomy,
the single anarchist making his
decision to go out and
kill--individual autonomy.
And, thus, I use the
description of this lecture,
for better or for worse,
as dynamite club;
but dynamite club was the
perception of,
not the police because they
knew better,
but of the public,
that imagined that behind every
incident, every sardine can,
was a nefarious plot to destroy
organized society.
There was no club,
but there were some violent
individuals capable
of--minorities within the
anarchist movement--of doing
deeds.
On the eleventh--backing up one
year, for reasons we'll see--the
eleventh of November,
1892, an employee of the mine
company of Carmaux,
those mining strikes that had
catapulted Jaurès to
fame,
found a suspicious looking
package on the floor outside the
company door at eleven Avenue de
L'Opéra--there,
eleven, up on the left.
This is 1900, this picture.
I've gotten in that building
too, my son and I did,
and I showed him where he put
the bomb;
it's still a very elegant
building.
And they carried it downstairs
rather stupidly,
placed it on the sidewalk at
the back entrance,
and a policeman came along and
said, "well you better take it
to the police station,"
not noticing that there were
little powders that seemed to be
coming out of this machine,
as they used to call them in
those days.
It was a reversible bomb,
it was a bomb not made by a
fuse but by chemicals and when
they came together would blow
up.
And so these poor policemen are
carrying it to the nearest
police station,
which is there--no,
that's the building now;
you can get into it,
it's on the first floor.
I love stuff like that,
just love it.
That's the police station,
which is still there also.
And, so, they carry it through
the first courtyard.
One guy says,
"hurry up, it's heavy."
It was a heavy thing.
They put it in,
put it down on the table and
boom, arms, legs everywhere,
gone, five people killed in the
most horrible way.
The bomb had been wrapped in a
newspaper, the issue of Le
Temps, from June first,
1892, which related the story
of the arrest of Émile
Henry and his brother.
Émile Henry left Paris
the next day for London,
sending along his apologies.
He was on a list of one hundred
and thirty suspects.
He hangs around Fitzroy
Square--which now is so
expensive, so,
with Charlotte Street,
just full of one fancy
unaffordable restaurant after
another--he hangs around with
the anarchists there.
A friend of Oscar Wilde's
remembered meeting him there.
He spoke some English,
but not terribly well.
Once he told people,
"today is the anniversary of
the dancing lesson," by which he
meant bodies jumping up and
down,
in their last final agony,
in the police station.
He was proud,
he had exterminated six
enemies.
Malato said,
"he grew in his own eyes.
He said to himself that his
role as a destroying angel had
just begun."
But, why didn't they think he
was a serious suspect?
Well, because a policeman that
particular day,
that day, November 8th,
1892, he'd gone to work near
the Gare du Nord,
the Station of the North.
He had two errands to do;
one was near the Church of the
Madeline, the second was way up
by--near the Arc d'Triomphe.
His boss gave him some money to
do these errands.
And a policeman tried to do the
same thing, and said that he
could not have gone back to his
house in Montmartre,
to the fifth floor,
Rue Veron--it doesn't matter,
I love this stuff--and got the
bomb,
gone all the way back down to
the Avenue de l'Opèra,
and then finished his errands
and got back in two hours and
fifteen minutes--pas
possible.
So, I did it.
I replaced tramway and omnibus
with buses and metros,
and I replaced a carriage--I
never take cabs--with a cab,
and my cab couldn't turn left
on the Avenue de l'Opèra,
so I subtracted 11 minutes.
I paused--I couldn't get that
day into one of his houses where
he put the bomb.
And I came back in about two
hours and fifteen or sixteen
minutes.
Somebody did the same thing in
1894, and said he certainly
could have done it.
Anyway, old Émile is off
in London.
Now, I'm just trying now to
imagine what he imagined.
What converts him to anarchism
was the appalling gap between
the wealthy and the poor in
Paris, and other places.
The heritage of the father,
of course, had something to do
with it.
Never had people lived it up in
such flamboyant,
one could even say egregious
ways,
as in Paris in the Belle
Époque,
the so-called Gay ‘90s.
Now, the nostalgia for that is
a creation, really,
of how horrible things would be
later with World War I,
but still--and the Belle
Époque was not
belle for very many
people.
But what leads him to anarchism
is that.
Everywhere he lived--that was
the only place,
the exception a minute ago,
which was near the
Bastille--everywhere he lived
was on the edge of Paris,
and everywhere he lived,
the facades of the buildings
are still the same.
This is one that's near
Montmartre--and they're building
Sacré-Coeur,
this is from that same time.
It hadn't been completed yet
but--and its big bell drowning
out the whole city,
hadn't been put in there,
but this--Sacré-Coeur
was built where the Commune had
started,
and it was seen as a monument
of penance for the Government of
the Moral Order.
And, so, they hated this and
they refer constantly to this.
They have fantasies.
Zola wrote a novel called
Paris in 1898,
which is modeled after
Émile Henry and some of
these other people.
And the brother of this priest
who, like the REM record,
is losing his religion,
he has these fantasies about
blowing up Sacré-Coeur.
And Émile Henry lived
near there, he lived on the Rue
Véron,
which is now fairly chic.
He lived on the top floor up
there.
That's where he went to get the
bomb.
And then he moves into this
place.
It says Villa Faucheur,
and that's not fancy at all.
And this is the same
façade.
He lived on the inside there in
1894.
And I went up there because I
got to see, I got to see.
And this is a pretty sketchy
neighborhood and there are a lot
of dealers,
drug deals going on here,
and I didn't want to look like
a flic en civil,
a plain- clothes cop,
and I don't want--I don't want
to look like I'm a wealthy
tourist,
either.
And, so, I kind of hid behind a
truck and took pictures and then
I walked in and said something
like, "salut les gars."
And I had to see.
But, when you walk out of
this-- that's how you got in,
that's 1894-- when you walk out
of this,
you turn right and there is the
Park of Belleville,
and down below the Place de la
Roquette where he would lose his
head,
and he looked out--he was
lucky, he couldn't see the Tour
Montparnasse,
which didn't then exist,
but he could see symbols that
he hated.
There was the Tour Eiffel that
had only been there--the Eiffel
Tower had been there for five
years.
There was the Pantheon,
where the State commemorated
its heroes, and there was Notre
Dame, which he hated as well.
And, so, he once wrote that
love can lead you to hate--he
wrote that before he was
guillotined, and he hated;
he loved humanity in the
abstract.
He loved his mom too.
But he loved humanity and he
hated the State,
and so he set out to kill.
So, these are sort of visual
signifiers, I guess in the new
cultural history they would call
them,
these buildings upon which--or
these monuments that he looked
down and hated.
If you've read Balzac's Old
Goriot ever in your reading
career, at the very end of the
story Rastignac is up at
Père Lachaise Cemetery,
and he--and poor--Père
Lachaise is not poor,
but the area around it is--and
he gestures down to western
Paris,
the fancy Paris,
and he says the equivalent of,
"it's war between you and me
now,
baby."
But he wanted to make the big
time, he wanted to sleep with
the right people,
he wanted to just do better and
better, for himself.
And Émile Henry says,
points down in those
neighborhoods,
and he says,
"it's war between you and me
now, baby."
And he meant it.
And he built bombs and he went
out to kill, at a time when
anarchist deeds were being
celebrated by some anarchists.
The explosive device that he
threw into the Café
Terminus, February 1894,
hit a chandelier,
then a marble table,
and fell to the ground
exploding.
Twenty people were wounded,
of whom one later died.
Broken glass,
pieces of tables and chairs,
blood and injured people,
fear was everywhere.
An architect had five wounds,
a draftsman seventeen.
Henry had seen--had been seen,
he'd after all sipped his
second beer, first also,
and at one point,
not so he wouldn't be
caught--so we can rule out
indirect suicide,
which I'll talk about just
briefly in a minute--he said,
"oh, where's the scoundrel that
did this?"
and runs away.
And he's chased by policemen,
by an apprentice barber,
by a contrôleur
from the tramway,
and they finally catch him
around the corner from the Gare
Saint-Lazare,
and he fires point blank with
his pistol.
He also had--his knife had
poison on it,
as well.
One policeman called Poisson
was very lucky to have escaped
with his life,
because his big wallet was hit
by one of these shots.
And, so, he's put in prison
here, in the
Conciergerie--and that
cell no longer exists,
that he was in.
Danton, and Robespierre,
and Marie Antoinette,
and Louis XVI were also in this
prison.
And one of the great sources
about this guy's life was the
prison guards,
because they're trying to get
information out of him,
and he tries to convert them to
anarchism, and they have a very
interesting kind of
relationship.
The first night he was in
prison, friends of his broke
into his room and took out
enough dynamite to make fourteen
or fifteen other bombs,
and so Paris is,
to say the least,
on high alert.
And, so, Émile Henry was
put on trial and,
in a flourish,
he saluted anarchism,
and gave a declaration for
anarchism that was read,
and is still read today,
where he says,
"you have garroted us in Spain,
you have hung us in Germany,
you have shot us here and
there, you have guillotined us
in France, but what you can
never do is extinguish anarchy,
because its roots are too deep."
Not surprisingly,
he was condemned to be
executed, and he was,
on the^( )21st of May,
1894.
And it's in early morning,
at four in the morning,
and the executioners all come
from the same family,
and this guy called Diebler was
the executioner.
I got to go back to that woman
in a minute.
This is Dibler,
who was called Monsieur Paris,
who was the chief executioner
and, for him,
one more execution was just one
more execution.
The last public execution in
France was 1936.
The last execution in France
using a guillotine,
of course, comme
d'habitude,
was 1972 or 1973;
I can't remember what date.
And the chill of that morning,
where people paid for seats on
the roof, and there were little
children whose parents bought
them seats as if they were--on
the roof as if they were outside
Wrigley Field watching the Cubs
from a roof far away.
Executions were festive events
for those people,
also, finishing their nights.
And there was always sort of
some speculation about,
"when this is going to happen,
when is he finally going to be
executed?"
And the scene,
which I've tried to recreate in
this book, of Dibler,
of the wagons with the wood of
justice showing up,
and with the apprentices doing
their work and putting up this
guillotine, as if you're putting
together this basically perfect
toy that didn't need any nails,
because everything fit together
so well.
Really, these guillotine scenes
were so important for
anarchists, also,
because it's part of the idea
of martyrdom,
of revolutionary immortality.
This comes from a Christian
religion also,
doesn't it, the execution
scenes.
Again, you see what I'm saying
in that, but these scenes of the
martyrdom and the use the
anarchists put to this are still
rather important.
Now, was this a form of
indirect suicide?
He'd fallen in love with the
wife of an anarchist;
and her building is still there
too, ironically not far away
from the place where he was
executed.
And he hit on her,
and they would go out with the
husband to his auberge,
and he would proclaim his love,
and she kind of blew him off.
Was it indirect suicide?
No, obviously not,
because he tries to escape at
the end, and then she,
in a real anticipation of the
modern life,
she is out giving interviews to
the journalists after his
execution.
She's saying,
"oh he loved me so much,
and one could well understand
why."
And the whole thing was just
incredible.
But it was not any kind of
indirect suicide at all.
But, what do I mean about the
origins of modern terrorism?
What was new about it?
Well, a couple of things.
Ravachol, Vaillant were very
poor.
Ravachol was a pauvre
type, a sad sack;
Vaillant was not,
he was a very honorable person.
Most of the people in Western
Europe--there were some
exceptions in the Russian case,
but these weren't anarchists,
it's a group called People's
Will--were ordinary workers.
Émile Henry was an
intellectual;
he was an intellectual.
That's new, but that's not as
important as what else was new.
Instead of targeting a head of
state, or a uniformed person,
as other anarchists had done,
he just picked people who were
having a beer,
petty bourgeois that he hated
because they propped up
capitalism,
and threw the bomb at them,
knowing he was going to kill a
lot of them.
He sat there and looked at
them--there's a very amazing
scene in The Battle of
Algiers,
in the movie The Battle of
Algiers, where this woman's
going to place a bomb,
and she's looking at people
that are going to die because of
what she is doing there--and he
looked at these people and he
said,
"I'm going to kill you,
I'm going to kill you,
because I love--I hate."
And that's really new about it.
Is it worth at all musing about
what this has to do with modern
terrorism?
I don't know,
just a few reflections;
there's no doubt about that,
that there are some
connections.
If you take Osama bin Laden,
for example,
he announced,
as everybody knows,
in the late nineties that he'll
attack civilians,
American civilians,
just like American military
people-- that's perfectly
obvious.
Another connection is within
modern terrorism you have this
sort of alliance between
intellectuals,
students, and people who are
simply down and out.
There are big differences also.
The suicide bomber is
something--no,
it's very different.
But, still, there are things
that are worth thinking about.
Third, the whole idea of
revolutionary immortality,
that you kill people,
you die, and you have
revolutionary immortality.
For many fundamentalist
terrorists you pass immediately
into this nirvana.
Fourth, both sets of terrorists
target a powerful enemy,
a structure they set out to
destroy and try to--"kill one,
warn a thousand," goes an old
Chinese proverb.
And they want to attack the
State and capitalism,
in the case of the anarchists,
and the targets are perfectly
obvious in the case of
contemporary terrorists as well.
Fifth, dynamite,
like roadside bombs,
are seen as leveling the
playing field.
You attack, you can prove that
you are strong when,
in reality, you are weak.
They demonstrate that powerful
states are vulnerable even to
small groups of determined
anarchists.
Next, also these groups,
as I said, their tendency is
always to try to find one person
running the whole show.
That's absolutely not the case
in the case of the anarchists,
as I already said,
nor is it the case now as well.
So, the French government then,
and officials now,
have a tendency to look for
centrally organized,
massive conspiracy,
instead of acknowledging the
role of small groups,
or even isolated individuals
undertaking locally organized or
freelance operations.
Anarchists, to repeat,
always emphasize the full
autonomy of the individual;
indeed, the potentially
murderous individual as the
case, as I've said.
And I obviously detest
everything that Émile
Henry stood for,
but I've tried to understand
his hatred.
Yet, there's one more thing
that could be added too,
is that when you think of the
word terrorism,
the word terrorism was
originally applied to actions
taken by the State to terrorize.
"The Terror" was terrorizing
opponents in the French
Revolution.
And it's often forgotten that
the vast majority of victims of
terror are victims of State
terrorism.
And the anarchists hated the
State because they'd seen up
close what State terrorism did
in the wake of the Commune,
and the beating of the police
at Clichy, the massacre of the
innocents, of these women,
young women gunned down during
the strike in the north,
or demonstrations in the north
in 1891,
must be remembered.
During the 1890s the anarchist
attacks, which were terrible,
killed a maximum of sixty
people--tragic--wounding more
than two hundred.
But, if you look at State
terrorism, the ratio somebody
has figured out stands at
approximately 260:1;
two hundred and sixty victims
of State terrorism as opposed to
one victim of this horrible
thing.
Terrorism has thus become part
of the political process,
but it's been called a danse
macabre,
or sort of a macabre dance
between states and their
fiercest opponents.
The two interact dynamically
and need each other.
The hatred of dissidents is
only further stoked by the
over-reaction of authorities;
it simply encourages attack.
And, certainly,
this is not a course in
political science,
but the reaction of the United
States government and other
governments to the horrible,
horrible attacks on September^(
)11th are a pretty good example
of that.
When states take tactics that
swell the hatred of their
opponents by abusing prisoners,
by torturing prisoners and by
that sort of thing,
that line between that goes all
the way back to Spain of the
1890s,
the first decade of the
twentieth century,
back to the Paris Commune
before that and,
unfortunately, to our very day.
That is the story of
Émile Henry.
See you on Wednesday.